the detested this comma asked me Oh Stan
see getting ready to test the car is a
cinch for jana gana know it the 29 year
old Finn is an engineer he works for the
Bavarian automotive supplier denso he's
become accustomed to the way the Germans
do business when asked about the
management hierarchy in Finland he says
it's informal yeah by mid level in
deutschland I think it's getting like
that in Germany to be not yet I've been
here for nearly a year and it's pretty
informal Jimmy cloaca talking to the
boss there's no problem socket saw some
chef Gerald's okay not really see but of
course when you address superiors here
you use courtesy forms in Finland we
don't even do that with strangers he's
hit it right because his company is
international many of his colleagues
come from Japan North Africa or India
getting skilled employees like them is
becoming more and more difficult for
many German firms denso was unable to
fill the product designer position for
months the head of personnel says she
spends lots of money trying to find the
best people she works with job placement
companies at the moment she's got 20
openings demarcus actually thought of
him the market is extremely competitive
our placement partners take a commission
based on twenty five percent of the
annual salary so for an engineer the
minimum sum is around 10,000 euros soon
with emulation open the fin janiers
agency is based in Berlin's Mitte
district partner annamaya mountains is
finished she advises her compatriots and
places them in jobs at German firms the
companies pay high commissions for the
service and back in her homeland there
are far more engineers than jobs
at a finisher start at the figures dr. C
consultation the Finnish government
created plenty of opportunities for
people to get a technical and
engineering education we've always had
lots of technical professionals and now
there are even more but with a Finnish
economy slowing down we've created a
surplus because these schools that were
developed produced many many engineers
and we don't need all of them in Finland
an appalling the I'll anything Finland
yarn or guard found his job through
annamaya now he wants the agency to
place his wife as well she would also
like to work in Germany but it'll be a
challenge because she hardly speaks any
German and bosses here don't necessarily
understand why they should employ fins
specifically as it I think kind it Nigel
they're not very passionate the very dry
and the humorous rather dry too but they
also say their films have a Protestant
work ethic they're reliable focused
quiet and do their jobs well lanzi need
to allow that invisibility money to our
transport in Finland Ellison or guard
works as an IT expert she would like to
continue that here she and her husband
want to stay in Germany because they
earn better money here than at home in
Finland fising is John I'm if nothing is
a bit smaller than Helsinki but we're
comfortable here especially on a day
like today possession is fit don't
people are sitting outside drinking
coffee having ice cream it's a pretty
place if she's this Sean like needs to
feel there might not be so much going on
over the weekend but it works for us
those
it's a nice town to settle in if Alyssa
norgaard can also land a good job